[Musique]
nous connaissons tous une personne qui
vit avec le diabète juste au québec
c'est un adulte sur dix qui vit avec la
maladie
parfois même sans le savoir le diabète
amène peu de symptômes et fait des
ravages à long terme sur la santé
un peu comme les fourmis charpentières
qui peuvent gruger toute la structure en
bois notre maison sont même qu'on s'en
rende compte
le diabète vos sournoisement affecté nos
yeux nos reins et le coeur jusqu'à temps
qu'il soit trop tard et que notre maison
s'effondre afin d'éviter que les fourmis
fat dommages irréversibles
les personnes atteintes du diabète
reçoit de l'enseignement pour changer
leurs habitudes de vie
le problème c'est que l'enseignement
actuel est très peu efficaces à long
terme
en effet les études démontrent qu'un an
après avoir reçu d'éducation sur le
diabète
la plupart des bienfaits disparaissent
comme si le patient n'avait jamais reçu
dans ma tâche d'abord voulu comprendre
pourquoi ce que j'ai constaté sic notre
enseignement est très peu centré sur le
patient
mais concrètement ça veut dire quoi on
donne de l'information patients sur sa
maladie sans d'abord évaluer ce qu'il
connaît ses croyances mais surtout ce
qu'il veut apprendre
actuellement on dispose en fait d'aucun
outil pour nous aider à individualiser
notre enseignement et c'est exactement
seul sujet de maths axe développé une
nouvelle intervention éducative
davantage centrée sur le patient
la solution la carte conceptuelle
prenons l'exemple de paul un homme
diabétique de 55 ans que je rencontre a
fait de lui donner de l'enseignement
comment utiliser la carte auprès des
peuples
tout d'abord j'ai cru un mot sur une
feuille exemple diabète et je demande
apple d'écrire des mots qu'ils croient
selon lui associées au diabète alors par
exemple paul pourrait m'indiquer que le
diabète peut mener à une amputation
ce qui est vrai toutefois apple pourrait
également indiqué que son diabète est
temporaire on sait que c'est faux alors
je peux passer des heures et les haras
enseigne à paul comment changer ses
habitudes de vie c'est pas le croit que
son diabète va passer tout seul que
pensez vous qu'il va arriver quand ils
vont retourner chez lui
absolument rien fourmies apple 0 mattez
vise donc à développer une intervention
éducative inspiré de la carte
conceptuelle pour spécifiquement centrer
notre éducation sur les croyances et les
besoins du patient
comment je m'y prendre on développe en
tout d'abord l'intervention avec des
experts soit un pédagogue des
infirmières mais aussi des patients
diabétiques pour ensuite la mettre en
place dans des milieux de soins et voir
ses bénéfices pour les patients
je suis confiant de développer une
nouvelle intervention indicative plus
efficace à long terme et si ma thèse
démontre que ça fonctionne pour des gens
comme paul l'intervention pourrait aussi
possiblement s'appliquer à d'autres
maladies chroniques et si révolutionner
notre façon d'enseigner aux patients
comme le disait nelson mandela
l'éducation et la main plus puissants
qu'on possède pour changer mon ce qui
j'espère me permettre de renverser le
pointage apple 1 fourmies 0